let's do some example questions dealing
with ratios so we're told the table
shows the number of people waiting in
line for different rides at an amusement
park so 15 people are waiting in line
for the roller coaster four people for
the slingshot 12 people waiting in line
for the bumper cars and 11 people in
line for the roundup
what is the ratio of people waiting in
to the people waiting in line for the
slingshot pause this video and see if
you can figure it out
so we want to know the ratio of the
people waiting in line for the roundup
this is the roundup right over here
to the rate to the number of people
waiting in line for the slingshot
so there's 11 people
waiting in line for the roundup
and there are four people waiting in
line for the slingshot
so the ratio is 11 to 4 or for every 11
people in line for the roundup there are
four people waiting in line for the
slingshot let's do another example
katie loves to read
in the last few months she has read
three graphic novels two mysteries four
science fiction novels and 21 comic
books
what is the ratio of sci-fi novels to
comic books so once again pause this
video and try to work it out on your own
all right so we want to know the ratio
of sci-fi novels so she has
four
sci-fi
novels the ratio of that to comic books
she has 21 comic books so the ratio is
for every four
sci-fi novels
she has 21 comic books
let me do that nuke that other color she
has 21 comic books so the ratio is 4 to
21 the ratio of sci-fi novels two comic
books four sci-fi novels for every 21
comic books
let's do one more example this is
strangely fun
what is the ratio of apples to bananas
pause this video and try to figure it
out
so let's see there are one two three
apples so for every three apples how
many bananas are there well there's one
two three four bananas
so the ratio of
apples to
the ratio of
apples
to bananas
is three apples for every four bananas
order matters if they said the ratio of
bananas to apples then this would be
four to three but they say apples two
bananas three two four three apples for
every four bananas